secret leila vous avez joué vous allez
essayer de donner de redonner les
secrets à chaque chroniqueur donc d
attribuer on a donc malgré les
apparences je porte un slip j'ai été
vendus comme esclaves dans leurs clubs
échangistes j'ai travaillé dans le x
j'ai fait un road trip avec colombo j'ai
déjeuné avec le pape je suis fan de
jacques chirac
je sais faire le grand écart sans
échauffement jouer chez vous tient sur
twitter http mp sur facebook sur la page
de touche pas à mon poste dites-nous ce
que votre avis ce que vous attribuiez à
chaque chroniqueur alors à votre avis
qui malgré les apparences porte un slip
je porte un nom le dit donc elle
isabelle morini-bosc comme ça à priori
vous la voyez s'en sont mis plein
elle parle dont l'aval est ori cassara
comme des fois j'ai des jus pour rendre
la joie de vie il vaut mieux un script
alors on va afficher tout de suite la
personne qui malgré les apparences porte
un slip
attention c'est vraiment bien ça vous
avez un slip aujourd'hui j'ai obligé de
le prouver
je vous laisse écouter savatan des
envies tout ça vous allait booster votre
carrière sexuelle attention j'ai été
vendus comme esclaves dans un club
échangiste à votre avis est vendu comme
esclave dans un club échangiste vous dit
allez leila christophe carrière après
les mondiaux comme esclaves dans un club
échangiste vous voulez qu'ils échangent
il a rien
je vous en prie non mais alors alors on
va il s'agit moi je suis beaucoup c'est
pas du tout c'est qui c'est qui qui a
été bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien parce qu'on n'en car il ya
une noria timide demande lui d'expliquer
charbon c'est bon d'accord elle enfin
c'est le truc normal c'est normal pour
lui c'est non alors oui des fois tu
faisais une enquête pour un journal
c'est ça ouais non caire je trop scam là
où les personnalités allait donc je suis
allé dans des clubs et dans ce club là
un club sado-maso j'arrive à une vente
aux enchères et comment elle chante
crise et chuchotements et donc on me dit
c'est vraiment aux gens c'est revoilà
donc bon nicolas lui c'est le job lui il
est capable de te donner le numéro de
téléphone les heures d'ouverture et l'ue
sont créés depuis sept mois je connais
faites attention parce qu'il ya de code
ci sont ensuite passés ensuite demandé
crise au sommet à ces essais en voilà et
donc je me propose pour jouer le jeu et
comprendre pour être vendus donc
j'arrive au milieu de la piste et puis
les enchères montent alors c'est pas de
l'euro c'est duke atteint le court assez
du cat 1 voilà papa tu vois je vous
envie de cerner ah oui alors ça monte
pas trop mais j'ai alors oui j'ai eu de
la chance parce qu'il ya une sompteuse
jeune femme qui a dit mais je vais être
vendu avec lui non hélas tous les deux
on a fait péter le truc des milliers de
catin ben j'imagine eu et c'est quoi
alors bah on a été vendu comme esclave
tous les deux non alors après il fallait
être esclave là j'ai quand même mis le
holà à wes à ce moment là j'ai juste
pris deux trois petites choses qui ont
les fesses comme dans la baie de hawke
dans la bouche c'est fou franchement je
m'attendais à tout sauf à vous à la
suite allé au 3g travailler dans le x
j'ai travaillé dans le x ou pensé que
c'était julien courbet
il a fait mais qui est déjà fait sans
aucun doute c'est vrai mais j'ai fait un
porno d'or dans le monde des fenêtres on
ou non c'est pas moi et ce à sa place
après portes et fenêtres ouvertes
alors c'est qui qui a travaillé dans le
x pour l'instant fait un sans faute dans
l'autre sens vous arrivez christophe
carrière je sers dans la vidéo que dès
mon avis ils remplacer les sexes avec sa
cause
[Applaudissements]
lui à mon avis sur les aides publiques
qui pesait doublure food excuse-moi
yahia patricia qui peut pas faire ça
sonne tu peux nous passer maintenant un
an et demi j'ai fait mais je me suis
occupé des rp de la plus grosse boîte de
x au monde non s'appelle private six
rites hathaway fred voilà et j'ai géré
pour deux festivals de cannes d'affilée
j'ai géré huard 2,4 ardeur pour michael
alors et vous avez banon figurez vous
non c'est pas vrai nom est bien mais
même là mais c'est à nous et on met le
ver dans le fruit et l'ac milan lab le
vert
j'ai fait un road trip avec colombo
alors je vais vous dire là je vois je
vois pas ce que je vois tout le secret
de nabila on n'a pas encore une habile à
papa tête colons alors je gère en effet
par colombo quoi se faire avec les
femmes qui aiment l'aventuré vous êtes
fan c'est vous non mais vous avez une
bonne productrice de secret story alors
que columbo dans l'équipe s'il vous
plaît c'est cesser ces jus lacombe et ap
quinze bornes avec colombourg ne permet
à vrai nom entre de limiter et lui sur
le siège passager dans la 403 beaucoup
on a fait trop autour de la plaine saint
denis c'est pour une émission
donc je faisais bonjean colombo un bien
un gars comme ça il arrivait un bonjour
julien d'eau qui monte dans la voiture
on a roulé on s'est pas adressé la
parole donnée trois tours parce qu'il
comprenait pas le français et peter falk
en fait oui mais colombo je sais pas
pourquoi on regarde cette fois lundi la
mère et ses magnifiques non mais c'est
magnifique mais bon c'est le seul truc
au bout de trois minutes tu sais qui a
tué ses cinq essais et oui
je suis dit tu vas mettre 12 heures à
regarder pour qu'à la fin ils disent bon
c'est celui là il aura soit pas du tout
ce que vous avez fait j'ai déjeuné avec
le pape qui a déjeuné avec le pape à
votre avis et elle a tout fait ici et je
n'ai que parmi eux aussi déjeuné à la
vie nous laver raconte et oui vous savez
même fait tomber votre bague twitter
c'était le précédent pas parce que
j'étais enceinte jusqu'aux u13 ils
aiment la cli 12%
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais pas je lance tu te lâches taku
brosseau ici les insulter quelqu'un que
vous n'aimez 12 mai pipelette alors
j'étais enceinte ça coûte tellement cher
les taxis là bas que j'ai dû coucher sur
des bancs en étant enceinte
ouais et le pape en en accompagner un
gamin qui voulait rencontrer le pape ne
pape avait accepté de le vendre en tant
que journaliste j'ai passé le week end
en fait avec le pam d'accord et en fait
j'ai pris un tel savoir moment j'ai
souris rats 7 heures du matin pendant ma
main ce que le pape a arrêté la messe et
m'a demandé de quitter le pape selon la
cimade une nation et après ma demi mon
ventre et où étaient les grandes choses
donc j'attends toujours
il a dit vous allez vraiment de choses
le pauvre il est sympa mais bon il
demain voyons ça pas le coupable
allez je suis fan de jacques chirac
alors c'est où il n'aura ou nabil a
alors à votre avis c'est qu'ils aient
nora qui est fan de jacques chirac
elles ont la trouille
on peut dire j'ai fait une campagne pour
jacques chirac séparez vous n'êtes pas
trop je le trouve trop chaud outre celle
ci ouais il est vraiment trop mignon
j'ai des t-shirts jacques chirac grobari
sur la vie de ma mère que c'est vrai
vous avez des petits shirt i love
jacques chirac mais gm se nomme elena sa
semence
c'est franchement c et voilà j'aime trop
jacques chirac et cela rend compte qu'on
le verra jamais alors c'est vrai mais
aussi jacques chirac non garde au toit
si jacques chirac veut nous voir
regarder et ben si un jour au soir il
peut pas venir deux secondes avec
permanent
[Applaudissements]
la ville a juste vous savez ce que vous
allez faire vous allez faire là il ya la
danse de la pluie
vous allez la faire la danse du chirac
vous allez vous mettre dans la caméra
fait une danse pour que jacques chirac
celle-ci ceci vous allez voir je sais
qu'il vous regarde vous voulez danser
comme ça
nous sommes très forts et j'aimerais
vraiment vous rencontrer et désolé pour
votre 9 mai vous je vous kiffe
je m'habille l'habitacle et n'aura donc
et n'aura fait le grand écart sans
échauffement mito série nadia comaneci
sur la vie de ma mère comme suit sites à
problèmes aux ischio jambiers pour moi
si je me déchire
alors la caméra et là il aura donc vous
savez la série des clones caméra et là
attention pas we all away
[Applaudissements]